[Musique]
ils forment le trio broadway depuis
trois ans à la maison des associations
des loges en josas un pianiste une
chanteuse et un violoniste bassiste joue
des reprises de comédie musicale c'est
un peu hybride ins et piano chant
d'accord avec le violon donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai rajouté la base parce que ça
permet de rentrer un peu dedans
différemment à quoi le trio broadway
reprend bien sûr des chansons du
répertoire des comédies musicales de
broadway comme west side story ou encore
my fair lady
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il interprète également de la musique
plus populaire un peu jazzy fier
[Musique]
il ya notamment du michel legrand la la
chanson de maxence qui est dans le film
les demoiselles de rochefort donc voilà
ça s'apparente à la comédie musicale
mais c'est quelque chose de français que
les américains sont réappropriés parce
qu'il ya toujours un peu un échange
culturel qui se fait il ya du henri
salvador il ya du barbara le trio
broadway quasiment familiale puisque
raphaël le pianiste est le fils de
daniel naud violoniste une complicité
qui se voit sur la scène le concert a
duré une heure et demie j'ai trouvé ce
spectacle original
très beau c'était super tubert bien moi
je suis jamais venu mais franchement
c'est à découvrir le pianiste et ses
improvisations sont bluffantes la voie
de la choriste aussi donc puis j'aime
beaucoup aussi la basse une centaine de
personnes étaient venues assister à ce
concert
[Applaudissements]